(dissonance)
- That's a close one.
- Are you sitting
on any green houses?
- Um...
No.
This is purple.
- Yeah, wrong game, actually.
- If you land on go, you
get $400, but I'm not sure--
- That doesn't make any sense,
because you're not
even going, right?
- I don't know if
that's in the rulebook.
- It's like the opposite.
(knocking)
- Hi Mike.
- Hey, do you have any more
of those little green houses?
- Uh, yeah, guys, it's not
a good day for me right now,
I'm really busy.
- Well little green
anything would work.
- Yeah, maybe we
could even use--
- No no no no, look, no,
no one's coming in,
not ever again, okay?
Very specifically, Wednesdays
are always bad for me,
so just, if you want to
mark that down a little bit,
okay, I don't know if
you keep a calendar,
because it's very
important to know.
- Uh, we'll just
come back later then.
- Yeah.
- Who knows.
Maybe I'll see you at one.
- Okay.
- Goodbye.
- All right.
I don't know, I
think it was maybe
the vent scenes or something.
- I've never seen it.
- I've never talked with
him, but I feel like I saw it
on a piece of mail
once or something.
(knocking)
(door creaking open)
- Hello?
(dissonant music)
Guess we could call it a tie,
cause we didn't
technically finish.
- What's the deal with this?
- Um, well you roll dice,
and then you take the dice
that you want to reroll.
- No, I mean, why do
we have two of these?
It's a waste of space.
- Well, what are you talking
about, we got plenty of space.
- This is getting
out of hand, Matt.
I mean, look at this place.
Monica's coming over later,
and I don't want her to think
I live with a total slob.
No offense.
Well, what about you?
I mean, what about
all this stuff?
This is your stuff.
- Yeah, those are all
priceless works of art,
and by keeping those
I'm doing a service.
- You need all of them?
- Yes.
- Who is this?
- There's only one of
those in the world.
- All I'm saying is that
if you are so worried about
Monica thinking
that we're hoarders,
I think that we could probably
both get rid of some stuff.
Monica?
- Yeah.
- That's who you said?
- You've met her
like so many times.
Okay, what about this?
- That's, no way,
that's the best thing,
it's got Sonic, it's in color.
- We don't have any
batteries for this.
Nobody has batteries.
Can I at least put
it on the maybe pile?
(sighs)
- Yeah, okay.
Okay, how about this stuff?
- That's the original sheet
music for Jean Baptiste Friso's
(speaks French)
- Okay, yeah yeah, but
you have six of them.
So why, you don't need six.
- Well it's six movements.
- This one isn't even done.
- True, Baptiste Friso
wasn't able to finish
the final movement
before he died,
but that doesn't make it
any less an important part
of the canon that he
spent his whole life...
Okay, fine.
- Cool.
There we go.
- Okay.
Garbage?
- No way, I eat off
that every single day.
- It's covered in filth.
(gunfire)
(dogs barking)
Are we keeping this?
- Definitely.
(sighs)
(upbeat guitar music)
(coughs)
(gunfire, dogs barking)
- Okay.
Let's see it.
Oh, this looks nice.
- Alright, so do you want
to take the bags of stuff
that we do want to keep
and move those into the kitchen?
- Umm...
I think I just got into
the zone of moving bags,
and I just--
- Oh no.
- Do you want me to go
get that one painting?
- Uh, no.
You know what?
Maybe we could take two Yahtzees
and like, stick them
together or something,
that like, does the same thing.
- Uh, okay, well I think
we kept two Yahtzees,
so maybe we could--
- I'm being sarcastic.
Jesus.
- Sorry.
- Do me a favor.
When Monica's here, just
stay out of this room.
- Okay.
(somber piano music)
- Do you think maybe
she's not coming?
It's been like five hours?
- Yeah, she's probably dead,
or has a boyfriend or something.
You got it working.
- Yeah.
Um, I found some
batteries that worked
in the emergency flashlight.
Sorry that I took
them out of that.
- No, it's fine.
(video game sound effects)
- You want to play?
- Yeah, sure.
How do I jump?
Is it A to jump?
- It's B to jump, A to kick.
(buttons clicking)
(crunching)
You have to kick,
you're just jumping.
- I want to be jumping.
- Okay.
(dissonant music)